a very special announcement for you
today the daily wire has acquired
created equal the documentary about
supreme court justice clarence thomas
and we'll be doing a live stream
premiere tonight
at 9 pm eastern apm central for our
daily wire members after that you can
watch on demand
so make sure you get a membership for 20
off with code justice if you haven't
noticed
history is constantly being erased and
rewritten you don't need to look much
further than uh
senseless creations like the 1919
project to see
that the left is trying to push us
directly into an orwellian nightmare so
oddly enough
it's on theocratic fascists like myself
to keep the history they want to censor
alive
otherwise future generations wouldn't be
aware of clarence thomas and his story
which he tells in the documentary
created equal
the film about thomas the second
african-american supreme court justice
was d-platform by amazon who has an
entire section dedicated to black voices
on their prime prime page but not
including claire's thomas apparently and
that's not all
in a move that's clearly that character
for the generous corporate giant they
removed his documentary from their queue
during none other than one of the most
sacred holidays black history month
that's when they took it down
they didn't say why they pulled it but
um i i can see why they would it doesn't
toe the party line
and it definitely does not fit the
narrative that conservatives are racist
it instead shows thomas's journey from
the segregated south to the highest
court in the land
and the all-out war that was waged on
him by anita hill and the left during
his confirmation it bears striking
resemblance to the brett kavanaugh
hearings
uh we all remember a sexual assault
allegation used by the left to take a
hard-working man's lifelong dream away
because
you know they can't bear to have a
conservative especially a black
conservative's voice in the mix
unlucky for the left they didn't beat
him and lucky for you created equal will
be live streaming on the daily wire
tonight
at 9 00 pm eastern 8 pm central so if
you need a good dose of
uncensored history make sure you're a
daily wire member
right now created equal is only
available to paying members and if you
want to help
us stop our technocratic dictators from
controlling everything
everything we see and read all the way
down to a documentary of a man
overcoming insane obstacles to reach his
goal
then just join that's all you got to do
go to dailywire.com
subscribe and get 20 off a new
membership with codejustice
it's a seriously excellent documentary
and all you need to hear is the famous
line from his confirmation hearing to
know
that you're in for a treat so here's the
trailer if you need a little extra
convincing here it is i was never going
to be white
the problem is i could never go back
completely to the world i came from
[Music]
i saw what i had become and then i asked
god and if you take
anger out of my heart i'll never hate
again you're not really black
because you're not doing what we expect
black people to do that's when
a heck broke loose so you'd still like
to serve on the supreme court
i'd rather die than withdraw from the
process
so you can see it there that's an
important story a dramatic story and one
that a lot of people
and if amazon had its way that nobody
would know but uh if you're interested
interested in the truth about history
visit dailywire.com
subscribe right now and get 20 off a new
membership with code justice and then
get ready for the live stream tonight at
9 pm eastern
8 pm central if you're still listening
to me talk and have not decided to
become a member yet
all i can tell you is that you're
missing out and you're hurting my
feelings too at the same time
so it's a great documentary but uh it's
not all the daily wire has to offer
we've got
a ton of great content and like my beard
it's always growing so subscribe now